you have the most incredible chemistry
with Lady gaga
you too it is an incredible performance
from both of you and you really do every
single second is completely believable
your relationship everything that you go
through how did you know that you were
going to have that with her had you met
her before I never met her before we had
passed each other I was doing I think
like enter the cage on Saturday Night
Live ever that thing and she was the
musical guest and we were like five feet
from each other years ago on and but
after that no I never I was at this
cancer benefit that Sean Parker was
throwing and she sang Libyan roads which
is a song in the movie yep and just
decimated the room and then I went and
saw her the next day I asked if I could
meet with her because I really don't
even know what she looked like or at all
yeah and and she was so present and open
and kind and it was just and it's one of
those things it just
I was hungry she made me food now what
she made she I love it you showed up and
you're like I might use you in the film
what do you got to eat that's exactly
how the audition was really hurt like
let's see how good this food is did she
cook did she cook you something no but
she sort of knew I was hungry I guess I
don't know what I was doing but she said
are you hungry and I said yeah and
probably salivating because I grabbed my
stomach and then we went to the kitchen
she and I looked she said look at my
fridge and then she had all this pasta
that's here maybe the night before and
she heated it up and I was eating it
with her and it was insane and then
right but she made me feel so
comfortable now I was act when I was
driving up to meet her I thought well if
we don't because we sing live we sing
everything's live in the movie and I and
you know that song midnight special yet
folk songs yep
yep and know the song I know that song
well I love that song and I said hey did
you wanna maybe we could just let's see
if we can sing together because I know
some piano in your living room and when
I walked in and you know the song she
said no I don't know it so we print up
the lyrics and next thing you know after
I'm eating pasta were singing in her
living room it was crazy and and she
said has anybody ever heard you song
before I said no and she said well let's
record it so recorded on my phone and
that was actually one of the FIR
things when I was trying to pitch this
movie to Warner Brothers I show them
that video
you